could you tell me about my mother please  we went everywhere together we were  inseparable skating on the riverbanks  dancing in the courtyard taking panties  off the houses when nobody was looking I  stay up all night in the flower guns  talking and talking  dreaming yeah your mother's room it's  beautiful  [Music]  this is my mother's butt and now yours  if you like  you remind me so much of her mother and  I used to dance and my family wonder why  I've gone oh no no you see your world  this much more slowly but Arwa you'll be  back before you even notice that you  disappear  if you want to go back I'm not leaving  without the key and that's that I quite  understand looking till then can you  keep a secret  [Music]